that movie Natural Born Killers is
another great film of yours I don't
think did you go in and threaten Oliver
Stone's life in the audition and it
freaked him out so much he gave you the
part it was a brilliant move on your
part right they were looking for this
crazy chick you go in on the audition
and say I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you I had
heard so many urban legends about myself
and normally I'm like oh that's so not
true or that's exaggerated and then I
went wait a second
the Oliver Stone audition was so funny
theoretically you could say I might have
made him believe I could kill him but
because I was well that's the part but I
didn't and I didn't like threaten him in
some violent way I I just sort of said I
explained to him
okay I'm Oliver Stone Juliette is this
premeditated in other words do you plan
the audition this way or does it just
happen spontaneously no I was like how
do I make him believe that
that tiny 120
20 and then that's when I sat across
from it I was like
killing someone is about finding their
weak points and the element of surprise
and you look at him Juliet you looked at
him like that yeah the way you just
looked at me yeah but maybe I was better
than what I just did just now but you
really put the fear of God into him and
then suddenly he could Envision you for
the part that he offer you the part on
the spot after you do something like
that okay so the audition for Oliver he
made me work for it so he I had to do
fight training so it wasn't just that
one conversation that I'm hired he he
psychologically made all the actors
think they didn't have the part because
he wants you to work for it so for
instance he wanted to know I was going
to be physically fit because that's just
a little scrawny skinny kid thing and I
am in that but you I I at least had to
train and learn fighting and learn how
to handle guns and stuff but he had me
go to his office he put a um a bar you
know where you do pull-ups yes so I got
to seven pull-ups that I could do and
then I had the job and I've heard that
you have to walk through a pile of
rattlesnakes and some of the
rattlesnakes are actually real
rattlesnakes with like real venom is
that true I love you the stories is it
not true no this is true this is my
Goose but you could die I like to tell
is that I literally walked through
rattlesnakes but let me say they were
far away they wasn't like um what's the
movie with Harrison Ford oh Raiders of
the Lost yeah wasn't like Raiders but
there is a scene where Woody and I are
walking we're stumbling we have to act
like we're on mushrooms or we're on
drugs do you take drugs for that scene
or do you act it that's a big
misconception you you cannot I can't be
on drugs and acting because you you have
to start over you have to know your mark
there's a whole technical Yeah medium
you have to be if you're hot you're
gonna [ __ ] that up five things you got
to play high yeah but is that what you
think about the times you were high and
then you can kind of pull from that yeah
you can pull from that but but even if
you hadn't experienced that you could
spin around like what are the early days
kids are getting high we'd make
ourselves dizzy but don't you think most
actors overplay being drunk or high yes
yes and and in order not to do that in a
way you gotta sort of downplay it thank
you look at this guy
this is exactly the way you play drunk
or Stoners you try to be so stubborn I
could do it with you right now look at
I think you've been drinking I think
you've been yeah I think you hit the
sauce last night on that plane no I
haven't no I can tell a little bit you
seem a little off and then it's the
heavy tongue like yeah so we can try the
whole interview I guess
foreign